same old song and dance that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
all right so what did i miss
well not much it turns out that i've
been gone for about a week on vacation
and tonight i can report that joe
biden's still an angry out-of-touch
blame-shifting desperate man trying to
resuscitate his morribund presidency
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism
that threatens the very foundations of
our republic
maggie republicans do not respect the
constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they do not recognize the will of the
people maggie republicans are just to
destroying american democracy
and just like that he declared war on
what 74 million voters
now it's obvious that dr jill and joe
biden's handlers they decided that the
only way to avoid a route in november
and to kick to the curb
joe biden in 2024 which they want to
avoid was if he went into a total madman
you know aura against magga
but the primetime speech was a tour de
flop a primal quack from a lame duck
president democrat senator maggie hassan
up for re-election in new hampshire knew
it was a problem she said i think
president biden's comments just painted
with way too broad a brush
even the washington post poured cold
water on it
and a white house official acknowledged
that the administration made a conscious
decision to include the marines for
symbolism
for some scholars who studied civil
military affairs the use of the marines
as a backdrop to the speech was unwise
said the post now buying this internal
polling on this speech
must have been really really bad because
within i think about 18 hours or so they
tried to claim that he didn't mean every
trump voter
i want to be very clear up front
not every republican is a maga
republican not every republican embraces
that extreme ideology but the extreme
maga republicans in congress have chosen
to go backwards full of anger violence
hate and division
but together we can and we must choose a
different path
nice try but we got your message loud
and clear joe
because the only legitimate non-fascist
republicans are for him drum roll please
the outgoing liz cheney and maybe adam
kinziger
well if you're a regular angle viewers
which you all should be by now you were
prepared for all this what was biden's
equivalent of a hail mary midterm pass
remember i think it was shortly after
january 6 that we warned you that the
biden doj would use the riot as a
pretext to just unleash a furious period
of demonization intimidation and
harassment against trump supporters
now as jarring as the actions and images
uh were from yesterday
it appears that the incoming
administration's response to all of that
will be freedom crushing from social
media censorship to a punitive justice
department
oh boy
we told you if they were worried about
another trump run for the white house
they were going to grow more desperate
they'd pull out all the stops to put
trump out of commission
it's beyond obvious
they're worried that trump's not just
going to run again
but that he's going to win again
and rather than take him on on the
court of ideas
they want to take them off the court
altogether
that was a week before the raid
now after the events of last week every
conservative working to thwart the
radical biden agenda
tonight i'm going to tell you this you
should assume that you could be
surveilled and targeted by the biden doj
now i wouldn't doubt for a moment that
dossiers are now being built
on hundreds maybe even thousands of
influential conservatives in office or
who are aspiring to run for office
after all the president himself said
that these types of people were threats
he said to the very foundations of our
republic
he said he's happy though to work with
people that he considers inside the
political mainstream
now a party obsessed with abortion on
demand
pushing genital mutilation on children
is lecturing us on what's mainstream are
you kidding me
now what the democrats want to prosecute
though goes far beyond donald trump
we've told you this as well they want to
use the full force of the federal
government and force social media giants
to hound and silence anyone who believes
in america first anyone who sees us
threatened by open borders anyone who
wants to take a hard line on china
anyone who wants to defund the woke
indoctrination of our public schools and
our military
and any candidate who insists that civil
servants stop acting like the servants
of the dnc
all of you are threats
they cast their opponents as
semi-fascists who threaten our entire
democratic system
but we're supposed to believe that
democrats are going to run the next
elections fairly
or that they won't use every tool at
their vast disposal legal or not
to stop those semi-fascists
now when you leak details of a grand
jury investigation to the new york times
in order to hurt trump
that's cheating
when you get a copy of trump's tax
returns and then leak them to the press
that's cheating
when you abuse the process to the extent
that a federal judge has to step in to
slow things down to preserve
time-honored privileges
that is cheating
when you use social media giants as
proxy sensors to protect the president's
son from scrutiny that is cheating these
people are masters at cheating at
abusing government power to hold on to
power
and you ever wonder by the way why did
we didn't find out who leaked that
supreme court draft opinion overturning
roe huh
what they've done to trump
they will do to anyone they think is a
serious obstacle
they will help their new poodle liz
cheney raise pac money to stop
trump-like threats to democracy meaning
threats to their power
yes that means ron desantis that means
tom cotton ted cruz josh hawley ron
johnson jim jordan jd vance you know
what i'm saying
look out all of you
even parents who attend school board
meetings they're threats to these
megalomaniacs
so bottom line
if you voted for trump and you plan to
vote for him again or strongly supported
key aspects of agenda and people who
support that agenda
they will treat you as a potential
domestic terrorist a fascist or a white
supremacist or heck maybe you'll qualify
for the trifecta
these days it feels like we are not just
at the brink of a civil war but that one
has already begun trump supporters are
already speaking the language of
violence it's no longer republicans
versus democrat it's americans versus
megan this hate-fueled agenda this
mega-republican agenda that we saw
incite violence on our nation's capital
has no place in a democracy
you can't exist
of course as they send poor biden out to
do his angry man routine it's so
pathetic
democrats are the ones doing the real
damage to america
theirs is a relentless assault on our
bedrock principles
on the idea of a politically blind
justice system
on our national sovereignty on parental
rights and education on our right to
free speech
but of course as the media obsesses on
the phantom maga threats the damage
is piling up and biden's policy wake and
it largely goes unreported
since he signed his
so-called inflation reduction act the
stock market has plummeted more than 3
000 points
now it's a stock market right it goes up
and down yeah sure but it's also a sign
that investors think we are in for a lot
more economic pain
and the green revolutionaries in
california are all supposed to be
emulating
they're on the verge of more blackouts
biden friends in europe they're facing a
cold winter and energy rationing because
of their stupid policies
and then of course the war in ukraine
that's not going well
biden sanctions on russia a huge failure
and putin and xi
they're now best buddies teaming up
against us great job
but we're supposed to believe biden's on
a roll yeah that's what they're saying
yeah he's at 42 in the rcp average
that's a juggernaut 42 percent wow
does this look like an energized crowd
gathered in pennsylvania to see joe
look um
there's a whole lot of folks here i
don't want to keep you standing much
longer
yeah if they're walking out that's why
and trump's rally looked a little bit
different
[Applause]
from now until the midterms
i want you all to expect a non-stop
barrage of bad news for republicans and
good news spin for democrats
i want you to take it all with a very
large grain of salt
the voter voters are going to decide for
themselves how things are going in
america how does it feel to their
families
under the leadership that they have
right now in congress it's up to them
but just know this
this period of intimidation
recriminations threats having the
military stand behind biden like that
this isn't going to
end
unless we end it unless they are
defeated politically we have to force
them to change by changing our political
leadership
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else